bonjour à toutes et à tous savez vous à
quoi ressemble et notre planète
il y à plus de 2 milliards d'années non
c'était bien avant les dinosaures
jusqu'à maintenant on pensait qu'à cette
époque il n'y avait que des petites
bactéries qui planait tranquillement
endormi
sauf que des chercheurs de l'université
de poitiers ont récemment découvert
d'étonnantes traces fossiles c'est
rassemble indiqué qu'il existait déjà à
l'époque des bestioles composé de
plusieurs cellules et que ces bestioles
bouger curieuses et curieux rien que
pour vous aujourd'hui la première
fibroscopie de l'histoire de la terre
bien sûr il ne s'agit pas des images
d'un examen médical mais des traces de
galeries creusées par les ancêtres de
nos ancêtres de nos ancêtres de nos
ancêtres
mais les enfants et les enfants de nos
ancêtres et peut-être même les premières
traces de mobilité des êtres vivants sur
terre il y à 2,1 milliards d'années
avant de tout vous expliquer je pense
qu'il est temps de faire un petit point
histoire un point même vieille histoire
même très très vieille histoire très
très très vieille histoire
4 5 milliards d'années formation de la
planète terre on pense que les premières
formes de vie très simple des bactéries
fait d'une seule cellule sont apparus il
y à trois points 5 milliards d'années
les dinos eux sont apparus il y à 250
millions d'années
et pour info nous homo sapiens on
débarque seulement il y a trois cent
mille ans et denver le dernier dinosaure
c'était fin des années 80 entre
bactéries primitives et dinosaures la
vie a donc évolué et pas qu'un peu mon
dieu jusqu'ici on estimait que les
premiers organismes complexes et mobiles
étaient apparues il y à 560 millions
d'années mais la découverte qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui repousse cette
apparition 2
1,5 milliard bananière swahili à environ
2,1 milliards d'années
bon cette date est estimé à plus ou
moins 300 millions d'années mais on
n'est plus à ça près c'est au gabon dans
les roches de cette carrière que les
chercheurs ont trouvé ces étonnantes
traces de guéret ils ont obtenu la
morphologie en trois dimensions de la
roche par microtomographie la
microtomographie fonctionne comme un
scanner médical
chaque fossiles peut ainsi être finement
analysés et sa structure reconstitué
vous vous souvenez je vous avais déjà
expliqué cette technique dans l'épisode
sur l'oreille de l'ancêtre des baleines
mans
[Musique]
revenons à nos galeries les chercheurs
ont voulu s'assurer tout d'abord qu'il
s'agissait bien de traces laissées par
des organismes vivants ils ont donc
comparé ces galeries à de nombreuses
structures naturellement observée dans
les roches mais ils n'ont rien trouvé de
similaire ces traces ont donc de fortes
chances d'être ce que l'on appelle des
traces biotique donc lié aux vivants et
les traces biotique c'est pas
automatique
bon là comme moi vous vous demandez
comment peut-on être sûr que ces
galeries ont été creusées par de petites
créatures il n'y a plus de 2 milliards
d'années et bien plusieurs indices
viennent soutenir l'hypothèse des
chercheurs les trajectoires que l'on
observe sont sinueuses et traverse les
différentes couches de sédiments parfois
à l'eau bic et même à la verticale
ces premières observations sont
caractéristiques d'un mouvement actif
dans un sédiment encore assez mou pour
avoir été creusée à l'époque laroche
n'avait pas encore totalement sédimenter
et c'était probablement une sorte de
vase donc les tunnels aurait le même âge
que la roche
vous suivez et il se trouve que cette
roche a été daté à 2,1 milliards
d'années par plusieurs équipes de
scientifiques et c'est pas fini
des analyses chimiques ont montré la
présence de soufre dit biologique dans
les galeries actuellement ce type de
soufre né retrouvé que dans les
sédiments qui se sont formés en présence
de matière organique
c'est le cas lorsqu'un organisme se
décompose sur place ou par exemple
lorsqu une limace laisse une traînée de
mucus darwin les chercheurs pensent que
les organismes à l'origine de ces
tunnels serait une agrégation de
cellules simples unis pour explorer la
base à la recherche de nutriments
recherche des branlées perdu la forme
des galeries nous permet d'imaginer à
quoi ressemble et ses mystérieuses
organismes mobile à une sorte de ver de
quelques millimètres d'épaisseur
allez je vous laisserai faire un tour
[Musique]
en tout cas on retiendra que les
premiers mouvements sur terre sont
probablement né dans le but d'aller
casser la croûte terrestre sur ce jvg un
brownie qui m'attend et pour ne pas
manquer les prochains épisodes abonne
toi
[Musique]